okay I want you to a different hair cell
in every video all right mark hurry okay
I'm doing I'm in hurry
ponytail no bangs go top five unknowns
I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Arianna ba
Surrey tough I'm unknowns they retweet
our videos whenever we do it so I guess
they must be cool with us to five
unexplainable and eerie YouTube channels
I love watching these kind of videos
because I like seeing but certainly
[ __ ] up on the Internet
some people say your reaction channels
are cancer what these YouTube channels
upload some random and cryptic content
most are quite creepy but some of them
don't have much information surrounding
them so bear with us we down by fire
meat sleep this channel began to upload
in 2015 and although they no longer
upload the channel remains creepy due to
its history it uploaded several videos
and various titles most of them involve
the cameraman randomly filming and
stalking people the channel racked up
more than sixteen thousand subscribers
not much is known about the channel and
who was behind the camera but a creepy
theory stemmed they had a video uploaded
titled long Pig this is supposedly slang
used by cannibals which means human meat
people were going to believe that due to
the videos that were being uploaded meat
sleep was a murderer and also
accountable some videos include one of a
basement in which there is a narrative
over it some speech includes you live
here and you're ungrateful
I give you
another video includes a short of a
staircase in which screaming can be cut
in the background No
of 2016 the channel stopped uploading
and set all of their videos to private
except for one uploaded On January 26
2016 the video is titled no more in the
video text appears which says things
such as meat sleep for continent 8
countries
11 participant if then went to explain a
room are known as rumor X the video
seems quite cryptic and unexplainable
however the description says it is over
ugly misogyny and stalking and
harassment it's too much sorry
goodnight number 4 away freedom not much
is known about this channel under the
name awake it began to upload in
November of 2015
its first video this titled awake it
asks us who we are and if we are a
contributing member to our society yes
it then claims that we are nobody it
sounds like something that you would
hear coming out of the mouth of Charles
Manson other videos seem to be coded
messages most are codes but others seem
to be a Russian text if you're able to
crack the code then let us know why
means each video has a creepy sound
playing on what's the name of these
cryptic videos who knows they seem to
upload frequently and the most recent
video was posted yesterday number 3
emotional found on 4chan
X on this channel is titled emotion it
only has 24 subscribers and has a load
view come it has a sequence of videos
uploaded titled video than a number most
videos are short in length and are very
bizarre for the most part there are only
still images but others of videos there
seems to be no context behind the videos
some range from videos of fields to
random texts will they ever reveal the
reason behind the videos who knows they
only began to start uploading two weeks
ago and their most recent upload is 5
days ago it was a one-second clip of
what looks like VHS static number two no
samba also filed on 4chan this bizarre
channel has a selection of unexplainable
videos it first uploaded on August 30th
2015 and as of now it has 11 videos
uploaded
the videos range in length from up to a
few seconds long to two minutes
every video has a creepy feel to it
their most grease is groovy oil was up
ended a week ago it was titled a
mountain in the video
a person can be heard reading out some
sort of binary code after this a person
in the mask appears and ends the creepy
videos are yet to be explained and as
the user doesn't have much subscribers
people within the comments haven't
figured it out yet can you figure it out
number one
AET DX although this channel only has
one video uploaded we had to include it
due to its popularity and how bizarre
the videos their first and only upload
was on May 9th 2015 its title is in
binary code if you translate the title
then you get the Spanish word more today
this translates to death
not much is known about the video but
soon after its release it grew in
popularity due to how bizarre it is the
video shows a person in a robe who has a
mask on the mask looks similar to a
plague doctors mask in the background a
strange noise can be heard after some
reddit users analyze the video there is
said to be pictures of women being
tortured sublimity placed within it
there is also hidden Morse code in the
video the video is yet to be explained
some possible theories have ranged from
film student to promos and even
terrorists thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed the video then
be sure to give a like don't forget to
subscribe to keep updated with our
videos goodbye I love when their videos
are always on such a positive subscribe
note wow you know this got me thinking I
should start something like one of these
things they get super mysterious yeah
we'll just make it weird and creepy
damn viral video here we come it untied
my shoe that's right on time oh and we
heard in the background that it untied
Oriana shoe know you can hear women
screaming I don't I can't get behind
this yeah that was creepy as [ __ ] that
was a for those who creepiest ones than
me going around the home with a flashing
lights and stuff like I felt like I was
inside the mind of a serial killer at
that moment it's so scary but it's more
scary that there were like 16,000
subscribers that's what's more scary
it's understandable I mean you gotta do
what you gotta do to get use you know
you know if there's a fan base for it
that's what I tell people when they
start up a channel the woman screaming
like that
okay this that particular video made me
feel like really uncomfortable because
of some of these other videos I feel
like this could just be someone [ __ ]
around
if something felt wrong about that video
no bad you should create our own - it's
just gonna encourage terrible step but
what will get views what will go fine
what is the cost of you dramatic I mean
people are trying to shut down reaction
channels I need a back-up plan
I love like if you figure it out let us
know yeah that watching you video by the
channel awake we want to make sure to
promote every channel that's know top 5
unknowns was like if you figure out the
co so even they're encouraging us to go
and explore these videos ourselves cuz
they know it increases their viewership
and their subscriber base
cross-promotion collab you collab with
these freaky channels and you use their
footage and then I collab with you
collaborate promoting your video showing
your video collab and then talking
making a discussion based off you talked
about Ariana
please I'm talking so yeah this guy has
23 videos 28 subs that's like a sub per
video I guess that's a good ratio
however dude emotion if you're going to
increase your channel you got to provide
something or edge
and this don't say that well I'm just
saying like me 28 subs is not a very
good start for 28 videos you gotta like
really work on those numbers man maybe
consider doing reactions oh my god no
okay the last one is terrifying because
there's like over five million views and
there's only one video on this channel
yeah it looked like he was doing like a
demon like I say ten lucky oh yeah one
ah ah clever and they said when he
translates into me death and ice then
your birthday things I said dad how you
say it in Spanish smart thing my dad
yeah we should name work one of our kids
that no more take get over here you make
me feel a lot the other one's gonna call
himself unknown like all these videos
I've ever seen of like creepy website or
creepy YouTube page people say like if
you pay attention there's really like a
woman being abducted and killed I don't
really take the time to actually go
watch the actual video however um if you
guys are using your time to do that
thank you because I don't have the time
to do that and I like knowing these
facts so if you're someone who's into
watching these videos keep watching them
that way we can get our information
better I don't have time I don't wanna
be offending someone who made this video
why I'm not offending anyone I'm trying
to help them get subscribers I know you
are being actually very helpful if it
ain't working don't keep doing the same
thing over and over again that's not the
line if you keep doing something over
and over again and producing no results
okay that's the definition of insanity
you're really butchering these stop
being insane and provide something that
is more raw never mind
ah
well that's it for this video folks if
you're new to the channel ladies and
gentlemen you can subscribe today and
become a reject
Ariana badassery is the boss she has a
Facebook fan page you can check it out
she also has an Instagram and a Twitter
and I want to give a special shout out
to a special somebody film SWAT you guys
are the reason we started doing YouTube
channels videos I've always loved
watching your reaction videos and all
the rest of your stuff just to post
really to say thank you and if you
wanted to give us a shout out on your
channel that would be massively
appreciated massive is a word that
should only be used for two occasions
one when there's like a something
horrible like a war going on like a
massive group of death and to describing
rains Venice Film SWAT what is your
channel for Scott or Scottish guys god
thing about film what else do you need
to know
oh I little bubbly beasts I'm sweating
alright alright see you sound like Oh
Manuel Steve I was setting and well as
built and I was browsing on Facebook
when I saw that there was a Jason Bourne
trailer that was a Jason Bourne trailer
okay man listen listen if you didn't
have the accent and you just sound like
an American dude I would think you're
like a boring creepy killer accent
accent really saves you a lot it makes
everything better
so be thankful for your voice because
your voice makes everything interesting
compliment
it's videos down on Rihanna you're free
to go fly away-way
ship to do that we I said stay your
jokes